[Music]
so I change the agenda a little bit I
write that down so that you know what to
expect so I'm going to first do the
topic that was going to come later I
realized actually reasonably Elementary
but new I mean it's something that many
of you won't have seen so I'm going to
do that first then SVD then the SVD for
large matrices will define these massive
matrices all like it's like big data but
we'll define that so I'm going to talk
about one particular sampling procedure
and I'll tell you what it is but it
turns out to be useful fairly widely
right for matrix problems so so this
this fields with quote unquote big data
right it's tacky term that's bandied
around a lot but here's our technical
definition of big data it's just
something that doesn't fit into Ram so
usually you think of algorithms like SVD
and so on traditionally if you will most
of the time you think of the matrix
being in RAM and then if I want to
access one particular entry I get in the
unit time any entry right that's how you
reckon the cost but that doesn't work
for big data so the data is outside and
we have to worry about how what fits
into RAM or not and so on we won't get
our hands too dirty we won't worry about
exact transactions input output you'll
see we'll find a clean way of doing it
right so obvious thing when you
encounter a very large problem is sample
so let's say I have a very big matrix
too big to fit in RAM and apply
algorithms I like to sample some rows
and columns and do whatever computation
I'm going to do it could be singular
values which I haven't defined I'll
define when we come to it
it could be singular values or it could
be today we will see something as simple
as matrix multiplication
interesting so we would like to deal
only with the sample rolls after that
and get an answer because it's not
always going to work right indeed one
thing that certainly won't work is
uniform random sampling so if I pick
rows all with equal probability there's
no chance that I would get a result an
error bound which works for all matrices
in a minute I'll say that we want things
that work for every matrix possible and
the reason it's simple right so it may
be that in a matrix a small fraction of
the rows or very heavy in the rest all
zero or close to zero we have to be able
to handle such matrices again I have to
tell you in what way we want to handle
them what the error bounds are but
intuitively uniform sampling won't do we
have to pay attention to how big or
small the entries are so we'll see I
said this lecture two problems I may not
get to both in this lecture so it may
involve part of the next lecture too so
one is a very simple thing on the other
hand it will be quite useful for the
next thing which is not so simple matrix
multiplication so I have two matrices
and I want to multiply them that's all I
want to do right I want to do it very
fast with sampling we'll see a way of
doing that again I want to get an
approximate answer where the error is
bounded for any pair of matrices you
give me write not random but the next
thing is something that perhaps you
won't have seen generally so it it's
going to use matrix multiplication
result in a funny way in not the way one
might be taking off but we'll see but we
want a compressed representation of a
matrix and I didn't I should have said
that there but the compressed
representation of a matrix is the
following what we will prove is that any
matrix can be approximated
given a small sample of rose and a small
sample of columns
so I want to get an approximation to
every entry of the matrix and the claim
is this is non-trivial they will prove
that perhaps only by the next lecture
but the claim is that whatever matrix
you give me if you give me a sample of
rows and a sample of columns that
suffice us to approximate the matrix but
the magic bullet is the probability
distribution with which you pick the
rows and columns probability for
sampling and as the title of the
lectures indicate it's going to
probability so going to be proportional
to the squared length of the rows and
columns here we are going to do only
with real matrices no complex entry so I
square the entries and sum them up the
probabilities will be proportional to
that this theorem will not be valid it's
not known to be valid if I cube the
entries or take the absolute value or
any of those things it's got to be
square and then we'll prove that for
every matrix you get an approximation to
the whole matrix doing this ok we'll
come back to that I first want to do
mostly multiplication both with sample
rows with probability proportional to
length squared as well as columns just
the length squared as a vector sum of
squares of the entries that is the magic
bullet
Wilding I will see why length squared is
the right thing to do but it turns out
it it does a lot of things will also use
length squared later for SVD length
squared sampling has been used for a
whole number of things will perhaps see
some but not many too many for instance
is the way to deal with tensors using
that we'll see perhaps later now
throughout this table so there are ok so
there are two sources of randomness in
algorithms one you can think of them as
either the other than tossing coins or
the data tossing coins so what do I mean
by that the algorithm tossing coins just
means there's a random number generator
available to you ok so
you you can generate random bits and
base your decisions on that these are
often called randomized algorithms the
data tossing coins means average case
analysis that is I'm not able to prove
for every input something something
happens I'm only able to prove for the
average input I take the expected time
over all inputs we do not want the data
to be allowed to toss coins here we want
to be able to do something that's good
for every matrix so data does not toss
coins for this for these two things I'll
do right but the algorithm does so
algorithm is randomized you could have
both you could have only the data
tossing coins you could have only the
algorithm as here or you could have both
all of that is possible so matrix
multiplication so it's just multiplying
two matrices right so we have M by N and
n by Q matrix a and B I want to find a P
if you want to do it exactly you can do
it in m and q time of course and you all
seen lot of divide and conquer
algorithms which are numerical problems
but they improve the complexity so I
would like to do matrix multiplication
approximately in a sense we'll define in
the error in linear time linear means M
times n plus n times Q ok now later I'll
talk about sparse matrices where many
entries of zero you can do it in linear
time for those as well so we will do
that and one reason you might want to do
it approximately instead of exactly is a
and B cannot be stored in RAM they are
big data so we want to sample and do
this this will be based on sampling can
we just take a sample of a and be
multiplied to get an approximate product
that's what you'd like to do well we
can't sample entries of a and B because
you know you don't know what to multiply
that you don't have compatible
dimensions samples some rows and columns
of AP which frozen which columns is the
question
like do i sample some rules or columns
of a and disjoint from that do I pick
some rows and columns of B and you'll
see well you'll have to think about it
suppose I pick arbitrarily some rules
let's say or columns of a but I don't
pay attention to which ones I picked and
I go to B and sample you should be able
to convince yourself not much can happen
you cannot do that you cannot do this so
that's also not going to work but
observe the following the product a B is
just a sum of outer products the first
column of a times the first row of B so
the column of a the first column of a is
a column vector first row of it this so
let me write this as a 1 dot I guess
sorry excuse me I think I use this
notation a 1 what is it so I think
something like this is for the first
column of a and the first row of B is
this right so if I multiply them I get a
full vector right so this is M by 1 this
is 1 by n I get a full vector M by n
matrix so that's a rank one matrix I
don't know whether you all seen this
identity is very simple but it's worth
checking of the first time that that is
correct
ok so the matrix product is exactly just
to some of these and n is the middle
dimension right n outer products right
and rank one things you should check
that at home
I just want applying matrices there's no
magic to that so the right-hand side is
the sum of n quantities it happens to be
the case that each matrix each
quantities is not a real number it's a
matrix full matrix right but
nevertheless the sum of N Things ok now
the first thing you think of the
evaluator some at least if they were
reals I will pick a sample of all of
these same quantities and if the
sampling probabilities are correct that
is if the variance is not very bad then
you hope that there's some you have to
scale it by n times R
to make it unbiased right you picked our
order then here to make it unbiased by
doing that you would hope that that's a
good estimate that depends on the
variance right it's not going to be a
good estimate for all probability
choices in fact it won't be a good
estimate for the uniform choice that's
not difficult to see so if I pick
columns uniformly at random there won't
be a good choice but this tells you
something very crucial so I'm going to
sample some of the columns of a I must
pick the same rows of B right this is
the sum so first column times first row
okay it's so I cannot pick disjoint sets
of columns or rows of B right whatever
columns are they I pick I must pick the
same rows of beef I'm going to apply to
this this identity to argue that things
are good which is what we'll do okay try
uniformly at random so you a are refers
to uniformly at random if I pick
uniformly at random a subset of columns
of a and same rows of B okay does this
work for every a and B okay so let's
think about that from it can you give me
examples where it doesn't work for some
a and B what's an example where if I
picked uniformly a random sample of all
columns array same rows of B right I
have to do that I would get I would get
nothing
I get garbage maybe the other
possibilities a is only one nonzero
column and B has the corresponding
nonzero row rest of zeros and you'll
never pick that right so if a looks like
nonzero here and all zeros there and B
looks like nonzero here all zeros here
this is a this is B then a B is not zero
it's not a zero matrix right because you
get that out this outer product tells
you something
but if R is not n R is not as high as
and you would almost never see this
column right the probability is only one
end and unless you pick n samples you
won't see that column uniformly at
random you suck
now there is a simple fix for this
example so this a and B non zero zero
and here if I pick a column of a with
probability proportional proportional
this is proportional to its length or
length square or any of those things
then you have a chance there is a chance
so if I did that I would pick the first
first column of a right that's the only
one it is nonzero so the probability is
one of picking this and zero picking
everybody else and I will get some
result you hope it's right now this does
not say you have to do length squared
we'll see why later but something
depending on the length right so you
have to do important sampling Ampang
sampling just means that probabilities
are not uniform
yeah yeah so I have not put up there a
metric itand sorry I will put it up but
for that I have to define a norm and so
on but what I want okay I should tell
you so I want the norm of a B - my
approximation and the norm I want just
it's just the sum of squares of all the
entries square so I want the mean
squared error if you will so Frobenius
norm i want the mean squared error to be
small now small so this is a square here
small in what sense
in this sense I'm jumping ahead a little
bit
I this is the mean squared this is the
square of sum of squares of all the
entries of a this is a B I want my error
to be less than or equal to that time
some epsilon okay again I will I will
state this more carefully this will not
be true for this matrix if you do
uniform sampling right you'll get zero
and it should be nonzero okay so that's
there's not work
matrix multiplication continued so we
write the sum I am going to just write
it in this sort of Matlacha notation
right so column I of a column and row I
of P uniform something that's not work
I'm just repeating that general non
uniform sampling I'm going to pick
column I of a and also the same row B
with probability P I so p1 through PN
awesome non-negative real summing to 1 P
1 is the probability of picking column 1
PTO's of probably picking column 2 and
so on
I don't know them yet I'm trying to find
them ok so the experiment I'm going to
do is pick a J one of the columns
probability of picking J is PJ
it's one trial I'm going to do and I'm
going to define a random variable X it's
a matrix valued random variable right it
takes on matrix values not real values
and the random variable is going to be
the picked column of a times the same
row B so it's one outer product right
I'm picking one column and I'm going to
estimate the entire sum by just one
which is not going to give you very good
at there but we will take an average of
many things later and then it will give
me a better so X is the matrix Y random
variable and really ultimately we want
to take iid samples or iid samples of J
and take the average otherwise the
variance will be too high right but
let's deal with one and find the
variance and we can compute the variance
for average of many things simply okay
so let's compute the mean and variance
of X and again once I know that I know
the mean and variance of the average of
our trials right so what's the mean of X
so it's a matrix for the random
variables so the expected value should
be taken entry wise or the other way of
saying the expected value is also a
matrix right so let's see what the what
the expected value is there Z so simple
thing so I'll go over perhaps as
possible so the expected value is just
with probability P J I'm picking J and I
get this right but this is not unbiased
so the expectation
I like the expectation to be a times B
I'd like this expectation to be the
matrix a times matrix B right it's a
matrix and I want that that's what
unbiased means right so any idea of how
I can make it unbiased but first maybe I
hint step back
suppose I want to estimate the sum of n
real numbers just real numbers now not
matrices for the moment I want to pick
one J with probably these are the
probabilities which I pick them how do
we scale the a J so that it's non bias
estimate for the song I want to define a
random variable like X right
I pick a J X is my AJ that I picked but
I want it to be unbiased I want the
expectation to be the sum so how would I
do that
some little thought about statistics so
I have to scale it right so it's I think
I put it down yeah so it's just a DA or
PD so I pick a J right and then that's
AJ AJ or P PJ has a great expectations
on bias okay so we do that so that's
okay so we I'm going to write one over
PJ it better happy j+ right some PJ's
might be 0 in which case you'll never
pick them so this is all right to write
still okay what about the errors so now
the variance right we have to worry
about the variance that's our main
problem try writing down the variance of
one entry IJ so in store variance try
the second moment the second moment is
so there are L Joyce's with probability
P L I picked alt I picked the LT column
of a and the same row or B so with
probability P L I picked the elf column
of a and the same row B so the IJ entry
of the product is a ILD LJ so my random
variable X the IJ entry I should have
written this down perhaps is this over
PL and so the expected value of x IJ
squid is sum over L so this is with
probability P L so one trial I'm picking
one of those the probabilities are PL so
I'm just writing the second moment down
so I get PL as the probability of
picking it and that's written down there
PL squid and I get AI j ai l squared L
now the variance is slightly smaller
than that right the variance of X IJ so
you all know this right this second
moment -
expected value squid what the expected
value does not depend on P the pl right
so this is unbiased so it's always the
same so I might as well so what I'm
trying to do is fare out peels that are
good that minimize the variance so how
do you bound it sorry
so there's that question okay I want to
say that I can disregard this term and
only look at this term because this is
constant my variables are the peels and
I'm trying to minimize the variance by
choosing the best possible TLS and it
doesn't matter this doesn't matter this
doesn't depend on the peels unbiased so
only the second moment matters so the
difficulty is we have one variance for
every entry of X which one do we
minimize well I'm going to take the sum
it's a simple idea but it simplifies
matters a lot you'll see without that
idea life would be complicated because
you each variance is different
but I think there's some of the
variances of X so let's denote for a
matrix valued random variable X let's do
not variance of X to mean the sum of the
variances of all the entries each entry
is a random variable sum of the variance
of all the entries okay and we calculate
that so we get so it's the sum over I
and J of the variance of the entry sum
over I and J of that sum over I and J of
that this is what we wrote down in the
last slide and simply this simplifies a
lot just because you can switch the sums
so sum over L that one hour pls come out
sum over I and J you get this these two
right okay sum over J of bij squared is
just column you just
is this a row son right L is the same I
sum over all J that's the length squared
of the row because sum of squares
entries and this is the length squared
of the column
right no nothing
you know very difficult here I mean just
so now I asked what's the best choice of
pl
so I want to minimize this the peels are
at my control right I can choose any p l
I want let's say for the moment what
choice of PL would minimize this it's
the one that minimizes the variance of X
I want to minimize that so Phi system
okay I'm sorry
this is something I said here so instead
of minimizing the variance we can
minimize the second moments since the
expected value this term is fixed again
I'm summing over all IJ so sum over all
the IJ here right
but the unbiased means every entry has
the expectation which is fixed it's
independent of P okay so I want to
choose the piece to minimize that so
again I rewrote that choose the PK I
guess I didn't rewrite it I change the L
to K so I want to 1hour PK times that to
be minimized summed over all K P has to
be a probability vector right so after
some to one and calculus which you
should do at home so if you have a one
through a n which are positive real
numbers I want P 1 through P n so that a
J over L over PL sum is minimized
subject to non negativity in something
to 1 and calculus you have to do this to
you know that should this maybe we can
just do it
so the point is that I'm differentiating
with respect to PL and right so you get
a PL squared in the denominator and so
you have to work this out but that just
will tell you that the PL are
proportional to square root of Al okay
just because you get the square here
that's all that's happening you get
square root check ok so the best choice
of PK are proportional to the square
root of that that's a product of the
lengths okay so you
take PK to be product of these two
lengths divided by the sum of all the
products so this is the the PK f to sum
to one so I have to normalize that
that's what I've done that right now in
the important special case that B equals
a transpose to leave it or not it's a
fairly important problem to multiply a
with a transpose now I'm not actually
going to say go into details of this but
let me back off one step and say why
this is important actually this whole
sampling issue came from a more general
problem of estimating the variance
covariance matrix of a probability
density so suppose you have a
probability density in d space so some
samples and i want to figure out the
variance covariance matrix of that
unfortunately that's denoted sigma
matrix Sigma I so this is a random X X
as a point right Sigma IJ is the
expectation of X I XJ provided after
centering so the expectation of X is 0
so 0 is the expectation of the vector
that means every component is 0 then I
take I I J at the entry of a matrix to
be distance is called the variance
covariance matrix so a question that
actually originally led to all of this
what in a way that probably I won't
describe is the following question how
many iid samples so this is an aside so
if you don't know some of these terms
don't worry it won't be necessary for
later
how many iid samples from a I'm going to
leave a blank here probability
distribution in RT do we need
to approximate sigma2 relative error
epsilon what that means is I'm a scaler
Sigma aprox that has the property that
the quadratic form is within 1 plus or
minus epsilon of the correct answer for
every week
so the question is how many samples do
we need because this is a very important
quantity estimate or quite often how
many samples do you need but the error
definition is very important without
exception for every V you must have that
the quadratic form is within 1 plus or
minus 1 so this question arises
naturally in for instance in regression
but it also writes in a lot of context
now so it's not for a general
distribution
so usually we worry about what I call
law concave distributions and gaussians
are among them and the answer we know
now is order D log D we didn't know that
till perhaps 10 years ago but now we
know that for every law concave density
it suffices to pick or divided by
epsilon squared it suffices to pick this
many samples and then the theorem is
that the sample variance covariance
matrix has this property is a decent
approximation to the variance covariance
matrix of the entire density right so I
won't prove that and again I'm only
setting this as an aside although this
was the original motivation but if some
of these terms are not familiar don't
don't worry about it and it won't be
needed in the sequel yes sorry
yeah
so we do need the multiplicative
guarantee it's the least I can well USB
captures right yeah that's why you need
this yeah it's like for linear
regression you need the least one so
yeah that's why so this originally arose
I mean actually so there's a rose in the
context of computing volumes of convex
sets and Lois and I formulated this
thing and then we proved some bound and
went through a bunch of iterations
before we got here these results are due
to Ruud Olsen with a functionalism
the proof is was very complicated but
now we know actually much simpler proof
of this okay a side over let's go back
there right so in this important special
case we get PK equals the length of the
column a squared divided by Frobenius
norm this is this is a norm of the
matrix which is sum of squares of all
the entries that's a right scaling
factor right because the numerator is
this you have to normalize to one so I
have to divide by the sum of all the
columns so that's that okay so hence the
name length squared sampling okay so we
came up naturally here in this context
right it's what calculus told you was
the minimizing probabilities thanks
great something right so that's why you
don't use length or length cubed R any
of those things length squared ISM is
exactly the thing that minimizes that so
this is called length weight sampling
and that was the title of these talk and
so for instance if I use any of these
okay let's go over this in detail so I'm
going to use excuse me I'm using these
probabilities right PK's I'm going to
plug them in the variance becomes I'm
going to plug them into that that's all
I'm doing right
so that's that that guy PK is this thing
divided by the sum so that comes up here
so altogether you get this thing cancels
and you get some over L length of the
column length of the row after I sum I
square them and that is less than or
equal to that Hawai is that what
inequality am I using to get that
so what am i doing so let's install
writing all those complicated things
let's write some over l al x BL squid
al is the first one bill is the second
one squid
I'm saying is less than or equal to sum
over al squid sum over BL squid and now
we know the name for it right so is this
cauchy-schwarz right or another way of
thinking about it is the dot product of
two vectors the vector a and vector B
and it's just saying that our product is
at most Gospel squared is at most a
summer space product of the squares of
the lengths right you get the same bound
if you used just a K squared so maybe
that's what doing so let's just do that
on the board
if big cake equals a K squared divided
by a f squared then I plug it into the
top there and I get the same answer as I
was getting there right so one over P
key a squid screen so this a case quite
just cancels out it's also in fact in
this case is exactly equal to a squared
B F square so so these probabilities are
the best this is not necessarily always
as good but the final lower upper bound
is the same okay so these probabilities
are the best right so if the lengths of
the Kate column of a sometimes it's very
high and at the same time so the length
of the case row B is low then this is a
better this is a better thing but that's
the best possible so length squared is
optimal for a a transpose which is our
basic problem okay so that's just I
think that just like that it turns out
approximate length squared is also fine
it gets you a good result good enough
result if I knew only within a constant
factor I need to know that the
probability of sampling is at least a
certain amount at most is not enough I
need to know at least for every K for
some constant then you get as good a
variance now this is useful because
there are matrices for which you don't
want to take the time to estimate each
columns length and then if you know an
estimate which has this property that's
good enough okay so so so that's what it
says here right it may be possible to
find such PK more easily than finding
all lengths
okay in that case you can use that then
you get that
so the unbiased estimator still divides
by PK of course the probabilities right
whatever it is it divides by that and
then you get the variance you get an
extra C there that's just very simple PK
has an extra seat compared to what we
had I don't know why I wrote Swan over C
squared excuse me it's 1 over C so
reducing variance is a standard let's
run over this so this X had very
interesting equal to that that's not
good enough why because the Frobenius
norm of a times b is that most of the
product of opinion as you have to prove
this right but it's not very it's just a
lot of algebra perhaps but it's a norm
its multiplicative it is it's not
difficult to prove you can do this by
writing down entries which is laborious
but you know whatever there there are
lots of these approving this I won't do
it you can check you can check that
equality could hold so even in the best
case if these are equal that's the best
possible that's the highest possible ABF
even then you get the error which is you
know if variance is only that much it's
not so good variance in general this guy
is greater than the phobias normal what
you're trying to find it's not a good
idea to have error greater than what
you're trying to find pardon me I I
should have had a square here so this is
variance of X X is a be two things
variance is a square square square okay
so that's not very good what do we do
what's a general method of reducing
variance we take s iid copies variance
cut down by a factor of s so with that
I'm going to state this as a theorem
it'll be nice if you can remember this
this is the term we'll use for doing
lots of other things like compressed
compressing a matrix so you have an N by
n n by Q matrix and we say that we want
this we get it approximately if C
is the following you pick j1 through J s
as samples
iid trials with probabilities P J which
satisfy this property basically length
squared right
PJ is proportional to the squared length
of the column J approximately you're off
by a factor of C little C and then you
form those column you pull out those
columns you have to scale them this is
making it unbiased right that's your
matrix C B curl B tilde is the matrix of
corresponding rows of B what did I do
here I picked one sample and I said take
an outer product this is sample 1 J 1
and then I wanted to take J to take the
outer product and so on instead I just
said put these columns into one matrix
that's the same as saying j 1j s that
matrix times are the matrix right
because matrix product expands into this
that's all I've done so I was taking the
average of s of these sampled X's and
that I'm just writing it as a matrix of
so then the expected value so what we
have already proved is that the
expectation of this is less than or
equal to that this was the variance
right so it's expectation of square but
so a B's mean was CB tilde we've proved
that it's unbiased
so the expected value of this is that so
I'm taking the matrix the random
variable I'm sorry I'm taking the random
variable subtracting its expectation and
taking the square and that's a variance
right the variance is this much we
proved that we proved the bound of the
variance of the matrix and that's that
and then so if you want just the
expected value the Frobenius norm that's
at most that so everybody
you know how does this imply that
everybody knows that right it's same
should hold same same absolutely holds
for picking rows of B correct and the
corresponding columns of a I could have
done that
so as actually a good point because
sometimes it may be easier yeah yeah so
it may be that's the thing it may happen
like what you're saying right it may
happen that B is something I know better
I know for some reason distribution of
the length squared of the rows of B or
if they give their physical matrices you
would potentially have an idea what the
length squared might be and then you
would do beans for they either it's fine
absolutely any any a in any business is
true yeah so that's another point worth
making again that it's true for every
every possible a and B if these quality
it's not interesting to prove results
that hold for most a and B because those
are very simple good you know the best
the optimal ones are a times B right
that's what you're saying right so the
optimal choice was length of a time's
the length of B instead of just one of
them I've just I don't I mean this is
the optimal choice so you if the lengths
are all that all their roles of B have
the same length
this can be cancelled and you get not
length quit sampling but length sampling
right so length squared comes from a a
transpose length squared comes from a
transpose right in a transpose it's
length squared and that was the central
problem variance covariance matrix was a
central problem you wanted to solve so
it's best and easiest to remember matrix
multiplication theorem by these words
I'm sure we'll we'll use some two or
three times but so it's nice remember
these words right so all it's saying is
that the Frobenius norm error which is
the second thing let's say if you will
goes down as 1 over root s where s is a
number of sample columns you pick for
length squared sampling so I mean
clearly the error will go to zero as you
go to s goes to infinity it's saying it
goes to 0 as 1 over root s ok if you
look at for being small if you look at
for being square it goes down as 1 over
s and I think this for this case it's
the best you can do you can't beat this
one of us
so in general all sort of simple
improvements of this or ruled out let's
just go over that let's see whether I
don't know whether the one that you're
suggesting so what you would like is
what you're saying is I would like the
expected value
a b-minus is estimate so you would like
this to be epsilon times the Frobenius
norm of a B right and length squared
will not get you that but it's okay so
if you're interested in the subject I
can give you references since this is
early work this is 20 years back let's
say so there have been a lot of attempts
at getting relative error and there are
some possibilities but much most
complicated probability distributions
are involved you have to sample columns
according to what's called leverage
scores so it makes life more complicated
so I won't do it here but I I can give
you a reference as well so something
like that is possible I'm not quite sure
in this problem but it's possible so
this can be much smaller than the Venus
no of a times this may be much much
bigger than this thing so that's our
problem we are getting a very large
error somehow so let me state it for
three tenses so propose a IJ K IJ K
going from 1 to N is a collection of
numbers and I want to maximize overall
unit vectors X sum of I JK JK X I XJ XK
if I had just two indices and a
symmetric there's an eigenvalue problem
this is the maximum eigenvalue for three
indices these forms are np-hard we don't
know how to solve them exactly but the
result the theorem is can find this to
plus or minus well it's really only
minus epsilon times the Frobenius norm
of e
which is this quantity using length
squared sampling is fairly complex again
it's just stated right I mean I won't be
able to prove that but that's true I
came for every tensor any a a ijk I can
give references to all of these if you
in polynomial time and so on but
exponential in epsilon 1 over epsilon so
epsilon is an important parameter you
can't drive this arrow down to too small
that's difficult ok
so big data so we are going to implement
this algorithm with big data validators
and fit into ram how do we do that big
data means it cannot be held in ramp
that's our again our definition we do
one pass through a and B and compute all
the probabilities PK so remember PK
could have been either only depending on
the length of columns of a or it could
be columns of a times columns of B yet
several candidate choices for PK we can
find the probabilities in one pass by
just keeping running sums right so we do
that by running sums of columns then we
store in RAM each of the P K's everybody
with me on this how we do this I mean we
got a compute the length squared of each
row of a for each column of a or each
row of B or the product of the column
and length you have to compute that for
each one you have to normalize at the
end of the day we will find the sum and
divide it so normalized by 1 so we can
do this with just order n space not N
squared the ramp
still uses n space it's 2 n square
with PK on once you have the
probabilities we can toss coins offline
to figure out which set of columns which
set of s columns away and the
corresponding rows away we are going to
sample okay we do this and then we make
a second pass so I'm thinking of now a
and B as too big to fit into RAM so
they're an external memory and the only
way you can access them is by making an
entire pass through the whole thing
right I cannot get one entry I can't
randomly access one entry so I have to
make a pass through the whole thing
right so you can make a second pass
through a and B and pull out the sample
so in two passes and then multiply the
sample matrices in ran because they fit
into rhyme and for error
okay so if I want error less than
epsilon times this s has to exceed C
over epsilon squared okay now what I
told you here seems to be a way of
picking one sample column or one sample
column of a and Rho B how do I do s of
them only two passes I'm not allowed s
passes so you know all the probabilities
you toss coins s times insert one time
and the S coin toss is tell you which s
columns I must pick I don't know the
second pass you pick them all out so
that's that's something simple then in
two passes you can do with well okay so
yes with replacement but it's highly
okay so some of the j.j T's might be
equal right that's what you mean
but you know with high probability that
won't happen because but yes but they
with replacement this whole thing is
actually there is a okay so it's I mean
there's a old result of half king that
says that without replacement is always
better
sorry--but I forget the variance is
bounded one by the other so
because convex function but yeah so but
I think but what I'm talking about is
with replacement in any case okay now
just a list of problems that now we know
how to solve I won't go over any of them
except the one I've told you sketch is
compressed representation of matrix
which I will go over that's our next
topic PCA principal component analysis
SVD it's coming you can actually compute
the SVD by sampling that is we'll be
able to sample again length squared
we'll be able to sample by length squid
probabilities the rows of a matrix and
do SVD on jester rows we sampled and we
can prove that that has an error bound
compared to what you would get by doing
there sweetie of the whole thing I'll do
this after I introduce SVD vanilla is
weedy and plain SVD and then talk about
it for a couple of lectures right that's
our next topic after that we'll see how
to do this tensor optimization you ask I
won't do it but again the well I stated
the result at least class falsification
again I won't again give you references
but I won't do that
okay now sketch up a large matrix so
that's our next topic I may or may not
quite finish all of this today but we'll
go into this and then come back if
there's if we run out of time so what do
I want to do I have a large matrix we
want will show our theorem is a can be
approximated given just a random sample
of rows of a and a random sample of
columns of a through whited sampling is
length squared it's not known for any
other probabilities right there is or
too much so for length squared we'll be
able to prove that so let's say first
intuitively let's ask ourselves can we
approximately sketch a matrix by a
sample of just rows the answer is
obviously no because the sample tells us
nothing about the rules that we didn't
pick there could be anything right
but suppose the rank of a is K which is
very small compared to M&M for a moment
so will be we want to do it for high
rank matrices as well we don't want to
do it only for the
but suppose the rank is K and suppose I
pick hundred K rows some large constant
times K rows intuitively without proof
we will prove things properly later
intuitively that should pin down the row
space of a right
I mean it's unlikely that I would miss
something in the row space unless it's
an anomaly okay so if there's one row of
a which is completely are talking to all
the other rows I'm sunk
I have to my sample will not get that
right so and I'll miss some of the row
space but as long as that's not the case
as long as no rows no small number of
rows completely orthogonal to the other
ones I'll get I'll get the row space
away essentially this is intuitive not
right so at least we can get the row
space maybe we don't get an
approximation to all of a but we get a
good idea of the row space now suppose I
pick order a cake columns of a that
should also tell me for the unsampled
rows what linear combinations we need to
take for why that things are not
degenerate so what do I mean so I have a
large matrix I picked lots of rows full
Rose I pinned down the row space of a
now I pick a fair number of columns
they're not adjacent columns now if I
look at each so let's say that I have a
none sample row here and I want to
figure out what combination of these
sample rolls makes this row right so I
know the row space there slice in the
row space row space I knew from the
sample and I want to figure out what
linear combination of the picked rows
gives me this okay how do I figure that
out I figured out what happens in the
columns i sample only in those I figured
out how what linear combination of these
circle samples entries gives me these
right
if I picked hundred K columns it should
pin down intuitively everybody sort of
see I mean so you know I have so to
figure out what combination this is of
the sample rolls I have KN ohms right
it's in K dimensional space
so I've K unknowns to figure out if I
have ten K circles here I have ten K
equations so if the system is reasonable
the ten K equations should tell me what
the combination is so I figured out a
good idea of all the columns all the
rules right including them sample ones
so then I'm done I'm not stuck with that
problem provided I have Rosen called
this is the intuition so let's say that
the matrix is not degenerate let's say
the following stronger sumption every K
by K sub determinant is non singular
nonzero that's that's the usual
definition of the you know strict non
degeneracy so then you're done right now
less strict this is a assumption that's
made sometimes for data is the rank is K
of the whole matrix but every 10 K by 10
K sub matrix has full rank okay full
rank escape no it'll be singular but
it's alright that's not unreasonable but
this only an intuition so okay so the
gist of the story is that if I pick
random sample of rows and I run on some
of the columns I should be home I should
be able to approximate every entry of
the matrix
we'll prove that but we'll prove it
interestingly using the matrix
multiplication theorem twice at least
twice right with rigorously proved the
error bound without assuming the day's
low rank this not an assumption we make
right okay so the picture of what we are
going to do so we have a matrix a which
is big in fact in both dimensions I'm
going to pick some columns of a which
form a matrix see I picked a few columns
if this is that stall as that yes but
not as broad I picked some rows that's a
real sample so this is as broad as a but
not as tall right and the assertion is I
can compute from C and are just given C
an hour I can compute a you to put in
between there so that a is approximately
equal to C times u times R now you you
have to just convince yourself the
dimensions are right if there's an S
columns it has s rows let's say for the
moment this is an S biased matrix okay
dimensions are correct and I multiply
just a sanity check okay so I will
straight I'll state the tail um at the
end but the theorem is for every matrix
a if I pick a random sample of rows
columns and rows according to length
squid that's important then I can
compute a you to put in between there
just from the sample so that this is
true I'll spell out there a bound
everything after a little motivation so
I think I'll give you one motivation see
this is used in a bunch of contexts but
I'll give you one motivation suppose you
have a large corpus of documents each
document as we did in the first lecture
is a word frequency vector right you
just first how many times each word
occurs in the document right so that's
your vector it forms a column of a large
matrix consisting of many documents each
column is a document matrix a as we did
in the first a new document which is
also a vector comes in we want its
similarity to each document in the
corpus or maybe you want a similarity
only to the ones with which it's fairly
similar a very standard notion in
nation retrieval of similarity is dot
product you could use other notions but
dot product is a very stranded notion so
we want the dot product of V with every
column of a that's the same as computing
this right we transpose a one of my aims
and going through this is you will
revise a bunch of linear algebra as we
go along this part for sure so here's a
problem I want to solve
I want to pre-process a I'm allowed a
bunch of time so that now query time
means new documents being presented to
me and I must find the similarity vector
similarities vector quite fast I don't
want to spend any cubed time for that
right but also we better be accurate
about this vector but for every document
V so when I pre process I don't know
which documents I will be faced to it
later right so I have to pre-process so
that I am correct approximately on every
vector V so we want to find a you let's
say so that use an estimate of e
transpose a so the estimate must not
differ by more than Delta times length
of e the length of these because I can
always scale V by a huge factor and the
error will blow up you can see and just
make sure that it's scale invariant
right so I I don't want to blow up the
error by scaling V so I want this to
hold but for every V no exceptions
because I don't know what the future
holds right so this has got a name right
so we'll set so we'll do this by doing
the following we will just approximate
we'll find you to be just V transpose C
you are see you all was in the last
slide and but that is a fast computation
so that's a fast computation because I
want to multiply by V transpose on this
side but C is tall and skinny so the
multiplication is not take going to take
so much time just think of the number of
columns as constant so it's just a
constant number of dot products right in
through vendor products and then
multiplied by you or multiplier R so
everything takes a constant number of
dot products only in surrendered
products that's a saving we got
what about the error I want the error or
maximized overall V and I have to scale
by the length of V to be at most Delta
okay
this quantity has a name the left-hand
side of the name it's a spectral norm of
a minus C you are so this is a chance
for me to say please read up spectral
norm if you have forgotten what it is is
this
but anyway it's the maximum overall unit
length vectors of V transpose C you are
let's say but the same as saying
dividing by the length okay if this was
matrices are symmetric with the maximum
absolute value eigen value they're
necessarily symmetric so it's a maximum
singular value it's a maximum singular
value of a minus C you are you may not
have seen what singular values are you
will soon but eigen value certainly you
know so so I want that to be small but
it's a randomized algorithm so the the
random process can give you terrible
results with very low probability always
possible I just want the expected value
of this is called the sub to denote
spectral long okay so I want the
spectral norm squared to be bounded by
something we will prove that if I took a
sample of s columns it's bounded by 1
over s to the one third one third is not
the best we know we know better things
now but what will prove is ways to the
one type so it's worse than the matrix
multiplication where it was square root
of s now it's a cube root where s is the
number of sample columns so it turns out
I'm going to sample different number of
rows than columns curiously so we'll put
this so so everybody and again I'll
state the theorem precisely last later
but everybody see what I'm saying what
I'm saying is any a I pick a random
subset of columns and a random subset of
rows as columns here smaller number of
rows and then I can guarantee that the
spectral norm difference is that
this much the slight problem with
proving spectral norm bounds and that
happens in a lot of other contexts when
when for instance you have random matrix
Theory spectral norm bounds require you
to prove that for every vector V this is
small okay
so that somehow not the trivial right
you have to prove it for every one of
infinitely many possible vectors so
Frobenius norm is a bit easier because
it's sum of squares it's a fixed
quantity there's not a fixed quantity
right it's a many quantities you must
through each one is small so any
questions on the setup
I should have said this on the slide
maybe but here's one question that could
arise so I proved in expectation at
least this is smaller than some epsilon
times for Binion away okay several
questions can arise first can I put a 2
instead of F here second can I put F in
store to here both would make like what
would make things stronger right so
let's consider the FNS can I do a minus
C F the answer is no but that's not
possible
so the that brings me back to this whole
thing right so that's not possible if a
is essentially high rank and simple
example of that is identity so suppose a
is the identity matrix right I pick a
sample of columns of a which is just a
unit vectors right a little bit of
thought shows you that I cannot get such
a fantastic approximation of a just with
those columns right so I'm only giving
you some unit vectors as columns the
rest of the matrix could be 0 all the
rest of the matrix could be identity
okay those two cases are completely
different and I can't distinguish those
two so there is no good low-rank
approximation to oh I should mention
this is low rank obviously right this
rank of this that most yes they're only
as columns right so so another way to
say this maybe I should have said it
clearer there's no matrix of small rank
that will approximate the identity very
well in in this in this sense or any
sense right so identity is essentially
high rank you cannot beat it so any high
rank essentially high rank matrix that's
where all the dimensions
I you're in trouble you cannot
approximate there's no free lunch right
and actually a similar thing applies to
the two also if I put twos both places
that's also not bandit again for the
identity but identity that's just one
the spectrum of the identity is one
right so you cannot do that okay so
these are the best two things we can do
on the two sides so this time I came
prepared with a lot of slides so I won't
run out of them and the hope is I've run
out of time before good otherwise is
getting from the heavier side so I'm
going to because the last 50 minutes
I'll go over this but then I might
repeat this the next time so so first a
intuition about this so the intuition is
interesting because it's very curious
what I'm going to do I'm going to take a
and multiply it with the identity right
using my lemma for sampling I'm going to
multiply this identity because I know
that a is equal to a times identity so
pretend multiplying a with identity but
by sampling sampling S columns okay okay
so we proved the matrix multiplication
theorem which said the error is that
most going down as 1 over root X right
and these will Frobenius norm
unfortunately the Frobenius norm of I to
sum of squares of all the entries is n
so the Fubini enormous the square root
of that right is root n this is not
interesting right so this is useless
because to get anything better than
Frobenius norm of a I need a s greater
than or equal to n so it's useless why
is it useless to get for vinius norm of
a on that side so suppose I want to
approximate a but I love you error of
Frobenius norm
so what can you do this is trivial right
it's not so interesting but how would I
accomplish this how would I get an
approximation like this zero right so I
could just take you to be zero zero
matrix and this is true so it's no good
so this this pretend multiplication
didn't help us very much because I seem
to need SS at least n but it will help
us you'll see now for seeing how it
helps us let's pretend that our our
transpose is invertible or is a sample
of rows of a are our transpose is a
small matrix R looks like this again
I'll go over all this in little slower
next time our transport this R by R this
is likely to be invertible we assume
let's assume it's invertible for the
moment the proof works even if it is not
why is it likely to be invertible i pick
a very small matrix and if you're not
degenerate it should be invertible if
that's not obvious you don't worry that
doesn't matter this is just an intuition
so RR transpose assume it's invertible
then I can define a matrix P which looks
like this
RR transpose inverse we said exist and I
multiply by our transpose here R and
it's not difficult to see that that acts
like the identity on a particular space
on the space of our why am I saying this
I'm going to replace the pretend
multiplication identity by P and that'll
buy me something that'll get rid of the
root and so ok maybe I wrote down a
proof of this ok so it acts as the
identity of the row space of a because
if I have somebody belonging to the row
space away I can write it as a
combination of the rows that's what I'm
doing to X so now P times X so P
operating on X is P is this and X is R
transpose Y now you get RR transpose
inverse or our transpose
they cancel each other out you get out
transpose Y which is the same as X right
so px is X so that it means it acts like
that acts as if it was the identity on
that space right identity is what we
want and it's not difficult to see that
perpendicular to that space acts as a
now it's the hole we perp perpendiculars
of space is device perpendicular space
is an isn't a null space of p revised
null space I mean so instead of pretend
a I am going to pretend a P now P is
somehow an identity on a very small
dimensional space our dimensional space
whereas I was identity on the n
dimensional space so the root n will get
replaced by root R because it's identity
on a very small space right and that's
it
that buys us everything we want we'll
get a root R by root s here where R can
be made it's on our control we'll make
it smaller than s ok so we left to prove
two things
we'll have to prove that so there a was
equal to a times I didn't - no problem
here it's not true that a is equal to a
times P but it is in a particular
subspace but it's not in the whole of
space so we have to prove that the norm
is small the spectral norm is small it
will follow from 1 & 2 we also have to
prove next that we're going to prove
sorry we're going to prove that ap is
close to see you on so I want to prove a
is close to see you are I proved a is
close to AP and then I prove AP is close
to C you are and I do that by doing the
following I now want to do a pretend
multiplication of a and P I say C is a
length squared sample of columns of a I
know how to do pretend multiplication so
I can do length squared sample of
columns I want to pick the corresponding
rows of P I will observe that in fact I
can do that that look like u times R
here's a hint why it might look like
that because P ends in all right P is
something times R so the sum of the rows
of P look like u times R we'll see that
so this is small by another application
of the matrix multiplication theorem so
it is as if we are doing a
multiplication of a and P by picking
sample columns of a and sample rolls of
P we don't do these multiplications they
are not actually algorithmically being
done this is for the proof right okay
then I think maybe I shouldn't start the
proof because we want to come back
revise all this and then this was not
the original proof so this was later
thought out by these tricks of employing
matrix multiplication as a sort of
conceptual thing this is the conclusion
so the difference is bounded by of some
function of R as well as s so
unfortunately our nice or not symmetric
so again we have n by n matrix RNs or
any integers satisfying some conditions
then actually they don't have to set any
conditions this is true for any artist
so we have length squared columns length
squared sampling columns then squared
sampling grows then we can find a matrix
you use s by our now notice by s to put
in the middle so that this is true for
spectral moment there is a result of
Frobenius norm which I won't State